il n'y a pas de risque sanitaire
immédiat les autorités se veulent
rassurantes après le rejet accidentel
d'uranium hier à la centrale nucléaire
de tricastin dans le vaucluse
des mesures de précaution ont été prises
mais la commission indépendante sur la
radioactivité la criirad dénonce le
manque de fiabilité de cette centrale
sur place le reportage de florence
trintignac et laurent beaufils imposante
et fumante la centrale nucléaire du
tricastin implantée au milieu des champs
sur le site l'usiné socatri chargé de la
décontamination du matériel et des eaux
usées
il est un peu plus de six heures trente
hier lorsque l'une de ses cuves déborde
à l'intérieur de l'eau contenant de
l'uranium naturel cette solution nuit
dans un bac de rétention qui lui-même a
connu des problèmes et cette solution
est allé au-delà de ce bac de rétention
pour s'étendre au sol de cette
installation
en plus de ça nous avons constaté une
présence de cette solution dans le
réseau des eaux pluviales
depuis hier les prélèvements dans les
rivières et dans la nappe phréatique se
multiplient
la solution répandu contenait 13 mg par
litre d'eau d'uranium naturel donc
faiblement radioactifs
au total ce sont 75 kg d'uranium qui se
sont écoulées même l'eau est clair donc
comme
ou bien clair et donc seule analyse au
laboratoire pourra permettre de
déterminer la concentration à quelques
kilomètres la palud la ville la plus
proche du site la plupart des habitants
n'ont découvert l'incident que ce matin
par les médias pour m
non pas toi
le maire lui même n'a été informé qu'à
13h30 ryer plusieurs heures après
l'incident
ces problèmes voilà c'est trop long moi
je pense que
on a besoin d'être informé plus
rapidement s'avérer joignable sur nos
portables à tout va depuis hier
après-midi la consommation d'eau potable
issus de forage est interdite
plusieurs plans d'eau proche du site ne
sont plus accessibles à la baignade la
pêche est interdite dans les cours d'eau
contaminée des cours d'eau qui tous se
jette dans le rhône